welcome back to CBS this morning
Gillan Maxwell will remain behind bars
until her trial scheduled for next July
a federal judge in New York denied her
request to be released on bail Maxwell
is accused of helping Jeffrey Epstein
sexually abuse underage girls
Epstein died by suicide in a federal
jail last summer national correspondent
Jericka Duncan is at the detention
center in new york where maxwell is
being held
Jericka why did the judge turn down
Maxwell's request
good morning Anthony the judge basically
said that Maxwell was too great of a
flight risk to be released from the
detention center behind me pointing to
Maxwell's finances and the fact that
she's facing up to 35 years in prison if
convicted
Gill and Maxwell barely spoke at
Tuesday's bail hearing answering the
judges questions via video link from the
Federal Detention Center where she's
being held when asked for a plea to
charges that she helped recruit and
groom underage girls for sex the 58 year
old British socialite responded not
guilty your honor
Maxwell the former girlfriend and
alleged accomplice of convicted sex
trafficker Jeffrey Epstein listened as
to alleged victims implored the judge to
deny her bail one identified only as
Jane Doe wrote in a letter that she
feared retribution adding if Maxwell is
out I need to be protected she's a
sexual predator who groomed and abused
me the other alleged victim Annie farmer
said she first met Maxwell and Epstein
when she was just 16 years old
attorney Sigrid McCauley represents ten
epstein accusers including farmer who is
expected to testify at Maxwell's trial
Annie really did feel like if the court
were to let her out there would be a
much larger looming threat to the
survivors than if she was imprisoned the
hearing lasted more than two hours
revealing new details about Maxwell's
July 2nd arrests in New Hampshire her
lawyers claimed she was simply there to
avoid what they called media spent and
retreated further into the home
when there was a disturbance but in
court documents Monday prosecutors said
FBI agents saw Maxwell ignore their
directions to open her door that day and
instead attempted to flee to another
room in the house prosecutors also
argued Maxwell is willing to lie to
protect herself
they said the real estate agent who sold
Maxwell her new hampshire stayed in 2019
told investigators Maxwell posed as a
journalist named Jenn Marshall when she
toured prosecutors further claimed
Maxwell hasn't been forthcoming about
her vast finances tying her to more than
a dozen bank accounts around the world
worth more than 20 million dollars
attorneys secret McCauley said the
judge's decision to deny Maxwell bail
shows her clients justice can be served
it renews their belief that the
prosecutors will move this case Ward
against not only Gillen and Jeffrey
Epstein but all of the individuals who
participated in these crimes
Andy farmers attorney tells me that more
women have come forward since Maxwell's
indictment now when the trial starts for
Maxwell which is expected to happen next
summer in July it will have been two
years since the arrest of Jeffrey
Epstein
Gail Voyager Rica many survivors say
they never thought this day would come
but here we are and they are relieved
thank you very much